Speaker 1: Really interesting story.
A Kremlin policy adviser is. Feeling
that he sees the invasion of Ukraine as shocking
and embarrassing to Russia. This is Andrei
Kortunov, who's been previously known
for defending the actions of Russia.
And he says he doesn't. This is me paraphrasing.
He doesn't know what the hell Putin is thinking
with what he is doing now. Let's look at
some actual clips of this. Take a look.
Speaker 3: I am trying to keep going. I'm trying
to continue doing what I'm doing. But of course,
I'm depressed. You know, all of
us are depressed and I think that.
It's very embarrassing for all of us, not
only because we turned out to be wrong,
but also because we're, you know, Russia and
all Russians will be in a difficult position
in in many countries, not even only Western
countries, but all over the place for a long time.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So I mean, listen, he's not quote
turning on Putin necessarily in the most overt
way. But this is this is a pretty big step back
for someone who's typically a Kremlin apologist.
Let's look at oh no, that's the that was the
only clip I had. So I think the the important
takeaway here. Yesterday, we had the story about
anecdotally, some Russian troops just surrendering
the stalled convoy. Not enough gas for
tanks, soldiers crying and taking food for
accepting, not taking, accepting food and drinks
from Ukrainians and calling their mom and saying,
I don't know what the hell I'm doing here. Quite
frankly, we're seeing that. We're seeing Putin
increasingly isolated, both figuratively
and literally sitting at the end of a 50
foot table from advisers that maybe he fears
might turn on him and try to kill him. Still,
no clear explanation why the table is so long and
why he's sitting so far. And in the middle, you
have everything. You still have a Russian military
that's so overwhelmingly bigger than the Ukrainian
forces that they have the ability they'll
they'll take losses, but they have the ability
to continue for a serious period of time. What
will things look like by Monday? I don't know.